You know who's next, make some noise, start it now!
For Markiplier!
Hello!
Hi!
Welcome, welcome, welcome.
Why is there another microphone here?
I probably just screwed up the whole
show by doing that.
But, Hello. Hi, How's it going?
My name is Markiplier, and I'm here to
share something with you.
When they asked me to come out on this stage,
I knew that i was going to be among
Other guests that were much more talented
and able to actually sing and dance
and do things like that...
You know, it's true.
But, the one thing they asked me to do was share something with you that I love,
And as some of you may know, as
some of you may not know.
The one thing that i really truly love is, Space!
Lot of space lovers out here...
- I LOVE space.
And when they ask me to share this thing...
and no, I'm not going to sing the song, sorry!
Ooh... Boo... ohhh...
No, no, no, I wanted to tell you
guys the story of why I love space.
And that really got me thinking about
you know, where that came from
where I fostered this deep connection
to what amounts to....
...a big nothing up there.
Umm...
But it really does go deep with me because,
if I were to tell the story, I would
have to go back to
My childhood, when I was about 12.
My parents had just gotten divorced, and we didn't
have a lot of money for video games
But my dad bought me this game
called Homeworld,
and I don't know if you guys know about this game
It's alright if you don't, but it's basically
a game about space.
And I loved it, i loved it number one,
because my dad spent what little money he had,
on this game, for me to enjoy.
And number two...
It was really a good game!
So I played the crap out of it the music
was great the art was great.
The vastness of it was wonderful
But, twelve year old me really didn't
appreciate it for what it was at the time
So I played it through a couple times,
and then shelved it for later
The next time that I thought about it
Was about a week after my dad passed away,
I was
I was in
Still in shock. I hadn't let myself grieve about it
And I found myself
I was working a deck building job as some of you may know and I went up to my boss because that particular day
I was feeling really off and as I should and I told him I needed to take a break
He didn't deserve like I didn't deserve to be paid if I wasn't going to work well
So I left and I went to my mom's house, and I I laid down in her driveway
and I just stared up and I look at the stars
And I stayed there for hours and hours, and I was just comforted by the emptiness of it. You know
I wasn't looking for any answers. I wasn't looking for anything to shout out at me. I was just looking up
Because I needed the silence I needed the solace I needed the solitude
And then I had a thought
something I hadn't thought about since I was a child I thought about that game
And I realized that I really wanted to play it again
And I wasn't sure why I wanted to play it again. I just had to play it again. So I went over to
My step mom and dad's house and in their basement my dad was a creature of habit
He stored everything meticulously that he ever had
Every book that he read every book that he published every
Every piece of cookware that was passed down to our family old grills that didn't work anymore
You know but in the back in the very back among all these bookshelves
was a game shelf
within meticulous order every single game that he had bought me over the years
And
Walking in I didn't realize it, and it wasn't until I pulled that game from the shelf and I looked back and I saw
This catalog of my dad's life
Then I realized
just how much I missed him
And so I broke down and I was crying and
crying, but then I
Open the game
And this is one game boxes used to be big so it's big big instruction manual pop the CD
And install it back in days when you had to install games of CDs, and then I played it, and I loved it
I loved everything about it. And I was grown up enough to appreciate how big it was out there
And then when I came back from playing the game. I was like 16 hours straight. Just stuck in my my stepmoms basement
Just playing over and over again crying intermittently
And then just though I and then I went back outside it was dark and I looked up
And it didn't seem empty anymore
It was everything
I understood, how vast it really was and I understood how big it was and how small I am
And that's not a short joke. It's not a short joke
But that's when I realized that
I had to let my dad go and I gained an appreciation for something that's so much bigger than myself
So anyway, that's what I wanted to share with you
Thank you everybody
I'll see you in the next one
Bye bye